a very different type of video today
dumb ways to die in video games I
decided to fail all QuickTime events in
a video game and let the enemies win
this first episode is all about the Last
of Us part 2
here's 101 ways to kick the bucket and
yeah there will be some out of context
spoilers but first here's 60 seconds of
Ellie and a be falling off things
[Music]
holy [__] laughs if they didn't sit well
with you I recommend turning off right
now because things get worse from here
on in it's just me and the weirdos from
now on okay
[Music]
here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
that's what the note said well let's get
down there
[Music]
[Applause]
we gotta get out of here fat
[Music]
Oh
if you stayed this long
you deserve an epic jazz solo from Le
take it away
[Music]